somehow most likely through some
nefarious means a fateful postcard has
been sent to one of the residents of the
murky mysterious ARA niram Island living
on this particular Island was already a
strange and scary enough existence given
the horrors the inhabitants of anariram
share their home with but perhaps the
only thing just as horrible as life on
that island was being sent a postcard
sure that doesn't sound all that
horrible postcards are usually used to
show a corner of the world far away and
extend well wishes from friends or
relatives on vacations but ordinarily
postcards don't depict a photo of
scp-096 with the words wish she was
there scrawled on the other side from
its containment cell at the SCP
Foundation the shy guy instantly sensed
that somebody somewhere had seen a
picture of its face breaking down into
an enraged fit
societal insecurity
scp-096 immediately broke from its
containment chamber and made a
cross-country beeline heading straight
for aaronerum at anomalously accelerated
speeds little did the creature or the
foundation know that the shy guy was
being led straight into a trap and the
poor island resident who had received
the chilling postcard while they were
unlucky enough to beat the bait while
the SCP Foundation started frantically
trying to track down where it had gone
the shy guy had already made its way to
a wooden cabin belonging to the
unfortunate postcard recipient emerging
from the now emptied home once the owner
was no more
scp-096 would have returned to his cell
just as quickly as he left that is if he
wasn't the only monstrous creature on
the island allowed and sudden noise
caught the creature's attention the
sound of an old steam train whistle it
rang out once more from somewhere or off
in the distance but there was so much
thick fog hanging in the air around
erina that it was almost impossible to
see anything especially with how dark it
was the second time the whistle sounded
it was closer but there was another
sound too and not the loud chugging of a
steam engine that you would expect it
was an erratic heavy thudding the noise
of lots of something strumming against
the ground causing the Earth itself to
shudder legs they were the steps of
multiple huge legs crawling across the
surface of the island heading straight
towards
scp-096 a third piercing whistle rang
out even closer still this time the
orange glow of a light could be seen
dulled by the surrounding fog but
getting brighter and clearer as it came
closer the light was casting Shadows
against the dark fog long spindly shapes
of spidery appendix
until before the Shy Guy's eyes a
creature of pure nightmares came
bursting out of the fog it was a
monstrous sight even to
scp-096 its body was the Red Front
engine of an old-fashioned steam train
hoisted off the ground by four pairs of
enormous black spindly spider-like legs
that propelled the Beast forwards at a
terrifying speed able to move without
the limitations of needing to follow a
railroad track the monster was barreling
towards
scp-096 with a twisted smile on its
grotesque face at the front of the
locomotive was its circular face with
its unnaturally white eyes and a mouth
that sported rows of razor-sharp teeth
all covered in blood this hellish
Abomination a being that was part steam
engine and part giant spider was the
terror of erina himself the carnivorous
choo choo Charles seeing Charles racing
towards them on its eight spider legs
would be enough to make anyone freeze up
and stop in their tracks out of sheer
Terror and scp-096 was compelled to do
the same except the terrifying train
creature's pale eyes were looking
directly at the shy guy as Charles sized
the anomaly up as its next meal he was
looking at it and that meant
scp-096 had to kill him the question was
how could it how could the skinny
spindly humanoid hope to even fight
something like choo choo Charles he was
much bigger even more fearsome but as
quick as Charles could move on his
spidery legs he was not faster than
scp's 096 in the blink of an eye the shy
guy raced off shrieking and sobbing in
despair leaving Charles to continue
roaming his island territory in search
of other human inhabitants to terrorize
scp-096 had retreated to some nearby
Woods quick enough to move out of
Charles's path somewhere it could hide
for now but the shy guy could feel a
familiar painful feeling almost pulling
him back towards choo choo Charles right
back into Harm's Way
scp-096 possessed an inescapable
compulsion to kill anyone who looked at
its face and that seemed to include a
horrifying part-train Parts spider
hybrids it was a fact of the Shy Guy's
very existence he had to go after
whoever looked at him and make them pay
in fact it took all the creatures Own
Strength not to instantly rush back over
to Charles to try
scp-096 knew that if it did then there
was little chance it would survive
coming face to train face with the
terror of aeronirum however while it was
watching choo choo Charles from a safe
distance seeing him crawl across the
landscape on his multiple legs that
scp-096 noticed something it was another
light obscured by the fog but this one
was much higher up one could almost
mistake it for the moon if it wasn't
getting closer all the while accompanied
by the sound of whirring rotors well the
shy guy had been evading choo choo
Charles the SCP Foundation had been
tirelessly trying to track down its
location and now they'd found their
runaway anomaly here on Aaron niram
Island as the chopper carrying the
mobile task force Drew nearer the
tyrannical train turned and took notice
to scp-096 the foundation's arrival
could have meant a way home and away
from the spidery steam engine but to
Charles the approaching chopper meant
only one thing a new source of food
Captain one of the MTF troops aboard the
chopper called over his headset what is
it do we have eyes on scp-096 the
captain replied before realizing what
he'd said well not eyes on because then
it would have jumped up onto the chopper
and killed us all I mean is there any
sign of scp-096 on the island negative
sir although you should probably see
this the soldier replied begrudgingly
the captain unbuckled himself from his
seat and snatched the foundation
operative's binoculars using them to
look down at erina below it didn't take
him long to spot the massive
multi-legged monstrosity that was choo
choo Charles but Fallen still waiting
for the chopper to descend low enough
for him to reach
crazy what on Earth is that thing the
captain exclaimed before taking another
look through the binoculars is that wait
what is an instance of scp-2086 doing
out here
scp-2086 was an Infamous anomalous
species the foundation had encountered
before much like Charles they were
anthropod-like creatures with multiple
long legs that protruded from a body
resembling a man-made mode of Transport
however
scp-2086s usually took on the appearance
of buses while in vehicle form sir I I
don't think that's an scp-2086 the
lookout replied to me it looks more like
an instance of scp-3023 impossible all
the way out here the captain retorted
we're nowhere near the region where the
anomaly occurs it could have scurried
its way from Germany and taken Nest here
sir the trooper responded yet another
anomaly that choo choo Charles bore a
striking resemblance to
scp-3023 was a rare phenomenon that was
known to occur at random but was limited
to a specific area of Central Germany
the effect of this phenomenon caused
ordinary everyday inanimate objects of
any shape or size to suddenly turn into
aggressive spiders sporting eight legs
That Grew From whatever was affected by
scp-3023 perhaps choo choo Charles was
indeed an instance of scp-3023 or some
distant evolutionary offshoot of
scp-2086 it was hard to say for sure the
only thing for sure was that Charles was
a man-eating Beast more so than an
Insidious villain and being so highly
territorial he considered the entire
island of Aaron nerum to be his natural
habitat and his hunting ground anything
that arrived in his vicinity was prey to
the terrifying train and his ravenous
craving for human flesh meant he was
ready to attack the descending SCP
Foundation Chopper right let's go go go
the MTF Captain called to his troops
signaling them to start repelling out of
the helicopter and down to the island
keep your Scrabble
scrap but first priority is taking down
this big ugly beast wearing goggles
specifically designed to distort the shy
guy from their view the team began
abselling out of the aircraft but choo
choo Charles was already waiting for
them rearing back on its four back legs
the nightmarish trained spider swiped at
the descending MTF operatives but first
seemed like an instinctive uncoordinated
assault quickly became precise and
Relentless strikes as Charles sliced
through some of the cables the MTF
troops were using to repel down their
Lifeline cut the Unlucky Foundation
operatives plummeted from mid-air right
down towards where the terror of
aaronura was waiting for them to fall a
few of the mtfs made it to the ground
alive and immediately began retaliating
against choo choo Charles the gunfire
from their weapons flickered all around
the carnivorous creature but their
bullets could barely chip the red
paintwork on his steam train body
dashing towards his helpless human prey
on his many legs Charles began to Feast
then suddenly something started pull at
one of his huge spider legs pulling
Charles back moments before he had a
chance to claim his latest victim the
captain of the foundation's MTF it was
scp-096 having zipped out of hiding and
shrieking wildly as it used all of its
strength to wrench one of choo choo
Charles's multiple limbs angered that it
couldn't reach the MTF Captain the parts
spider Park train hybrid stomped the leg
that was being pulled and a successful
attempt to free itself from the Shy
Guy's grip but in the same instant
scp-096 used its anomalous speed to
reappear in front of the already angered
locomotive monster with his railroad
rage about to reach its Breaking Point
Charles entered into a Relentless
Rampage making quick work of the
leftover MTF troops before setting his
sights squarely on
scp-096 but doing that was his biggest
mistake now choo choo Charles had seen
the shy guy twice and to the insecure
anomaly that meant Charles had to go
traveling faster than even the
multi-legged monstrosity could perceive
scp-096 began racing towards choo choo
Charles's many legs the Shanghai had
realized that it didn't stand a chance
of dealing with the terror of aaronerum
the same way it handled all the others
that had seen its face
so instead it had settled on a new
approach specifically tailored to taking
down the spider-legged steam engine one
by one
scp-096 started knocking Charles's many
legs out from underneath him effectively
tripping him up over and over again the
shy guy moved so quick that the
cumbersome Charles could barely react in
time having one leg after the other
knocked out from beneath him causing him
to Tumble to the ground normally choo
choo Charles was smart enough to retreat
if he encountered something that could
fight back if he was injured badly
enough the spider-like creature would
Scuttle out of Harm's Way in order to
heal his wounds but the rage at being
constantly tripped up by scp-096 was
distracting Charles from the Shy Guy's
true Ploy with every leg and knocked out
from underneath the spidery steam train
scp-096 had been gradually directing
Charles towards a nearby Gorge with a
terrifying burst of anomalous speed the
shy guy caused choo choo Charles to
topple over sideways rolling over
himself until he landed upside down in
the bottom of the Rocky Gorge the
multi-legged locomotive Monster's
spindly legs flailed desperately as he
tried to reposition himself but with no
luck
scp-096 had managed what first seemed to
be impossible and beaten the terror of
Aaron neram choo choo Charles or for now
at least now go and check out scp-096 vs
scp-343 and scp-096 versus
scp-106 for more